6. back here in the u.s the nation's  largest fuel pipeline  it is up and running again this morning  after last weekend's cyber attack  colonial pipeline restarted operations  again last night  but said it will be several days still  before fuel deliveries returned to  normal in that part of the country  until then the gas shortage is likely to  continue in the southeast  it is lead we've showed you to the long  lines at the pump price gouging  and in some cases even fights over a  spot  people run out and hoard that's going to  mean less fuel for people that  very much need it thinking first  responders front line workers who need  to get to work  because once it's out it's out according  to  aaa the national average price is above  three dollars a gallon  and that is the first time that's  happened since 2014.  president joe biden will discuss the  colonial pipeline and gas  shortage issue coming up later this  morning at the white house